it just as more years under my belt more
learning and knowing what I want what I
don't want yeah and what I won't settle
for Claire Crawley is officially the new
bachelorette it actually feels very good
to be back
Good Morning America announced the news
Monday morning and to be honest fans
didn't see this one coming
I'm shocked a hundred percent shocked
this is not a name that would have came
in my top 20 list before the
announcement Claire hasn't been on the
bachelor nation radar in a while and
she's not one of Peter Webber's ladies I
want somebody that when things get tough
will not run away but Claire is older
and she knows what she wants which might
make season 16 less of this I felt like
before but I've never like truly been
and loved so let's toast to the new
leading lady here's everything you need
to know about Claire Crawley's the 38
year old is a hair stylist from
Sacramento California I am looking for a
man that is just like my dad strong
loving gentle compassionate and just a
real genuine kind of moon she's no
stranger to the franchise Claire first
appeared on Juan Pablo season of The
Bachelor in 2014 the two were remembered
for getting hot and heavy in the ocean
we just went for it
I don't regret it but things were not
okay when Juan Pablo blindsided Claire
by calling it a mistake I thought I knew
what kind of man you are
okay what you just made me go through
mm-hmm I would never want my children
having a father like you okay Claire has
been on bachelor in paradise twice but
didn't find love she continued her
journey on Winter Games where she met
Benoit in 2018 he pulled off a surprise
proposal during the reunion special it's
insane girl I've waited 37 years for
this right Hey and as you said you
waited for the right man for you that's
true is so true I I it's hard to always
you know go through these shows and
people are like I look so desperate to
keep going on these shows but it was
never desperation it was always waiting
for the right one but they called off
their engagement less than two months
later being single is not negative
always and waiting for the right one is
not negative in my eyes so um it's
interesting to people because they think
they think oh you're so desperate so any
shows and it's like no man it's not for
lack of desperate you know it's not that
at all so is the fifth time a charm
there's a no-brainer for me personally
bachelor nation thinks so et spoke with
alums Ben Higgins and Becca kufran and
they think Claire is a good choice I
love that you know she is mature and she
does know what she's looking for and she
really wants to find a partner you know
we've been shocked with Colton when he
was a bachelor we were shocked with
Hanna B when she was announced to the
bachelor and that turned out great for
the franchise and so I'm shocked but I
believe this could be good I'm all-in
I'm excited I watched Claire I mean on
Juan Pablo season and then winter games
I don't know her but I'm ready to kind
of go back to the basics to you know
bump up the maturity left level a little
bit and to finally have hopefully more
deep real connections and conversations
and so I'm excited to watch her
[Music]